hola bienvenidos una vez más a este
encuentro semanal de canadá en las
américas café el espacio que le
proponemos desde el servicio en español
de radio canadá internacional hoy
estamos aquí un equipo reducido una
versión reducida del equipo en español
están presentes aquí en estudio rufo
valencia buenos días que tal como están
buenas tardes buenas noches y leonardo
gimeno que tal buenos días buenas tardes
noches
saludando sólo las que están de día y mi
nombre es luis laborda que no voy a
decir ni buenos días ni buenas tardes
buenas noches para nuevo soltar una
interactivo saludamos a todos los que
nos siguen a través del facebook live
que es uno de los canales por los que
ustedes pueden compartir este espacio
semanal y también recuerden que tienen
el canal de youtube donde se encuentra
también cada semana
versión digital de este programa versión
digital digo yo y en la versión web en
la versión radio como decía a días
pasados
rufo valència y nostálgica la palabra y
siguiendo el ejemplo de rufo vamos a
escuchar hoy más de un tema musical 2
vamos a ir tranquilamente con esta caja
pero vamos a tener entonces 22 temas
musicales para quienes escuchen el
programa a través del sitio en internet
que son de la artista canadiense jean
bernard que es de la provincia de
alberta de la ciudad de edmonton
[Música]
cultiva básicamente el género del rap y
el hip hop que son los dos estilos
musicales de los cuales yo no soy
necesariamente fanático ni entendido
tampoco pero me interesó y me pareció en
todo caso interesante la historia de
este músico que es un ex integrante de
una banda criminal ya me ve que en algún
momento decidió cambiar de vida se dio
cuenta que se dio cuenta que ese no era
el rumbo no era la vida que él quería
seguir y se dedicó entonces a militar
por los derechos de los indígenas y a su
vez por supuesto también se dedicó al
mundo musical pero ya ha traído
precisamente por el rap y en uno de esos
gestos de bondad que quiso tener luego
de haber abandonado el mundo criminal
sufrió un ataque por parte de gente a la
que él intentó ayudar que lo dejó
postrado en una silla de ruedas perdió
la posibilidad de caminar y ahora la
motricidad en sus piernas pero a pesar
de estar postrado en una silla de ruedas
no sé no se llama de trento y hoy en día
recorre distintos lugares de canadá
dos charlas a los jóvenes para que
eviten caer en las garras de las bandas
criminales así que ese es es un poco muy
sintética la historia de son bernard
vamos a escuchar de él dos temas uno que
es
haz tu negocio y al final learning de
paz
siguiendo el camino encontrando el
camino aprendiendo el camino hacia la
redención en su caso retención a través
de la música
exactamente sí señor así que quienes nos
quieran escuchar entonces a través del
sitio internet ahí tendrán esos dos
temas musicales y bueno cómo están
ustedes bien bien todos bien sigue ahí
pues siguiendo las actualidades sobre
todo esto este fenómeno mundial que son
los incendios que están asolando
distintas regiones del mundo entonces
justamente bien imagen qué
y guarda la memoria y es de ciudadanos
griegos que literalmente tuvieron que
meterse a las aguas del mediterráneo
mientras el fuego devoraba viviendas y
todo lo que encontraba a su paso tener
grandes juegos en canadá grandes juegos
en california grandes juegos en grecia
creo que también hay juegos en italia
así que creo que no hay no hay región
del mundo que esté libre de esto que es
obvio y evidente para todos lo que es el
recalentamiento del planeta sí claro
incendios que se van que se enseñó que
son en muchos lugares aquí en canadá
también habituales durante la época
estival pero que como escribí yo en la
presentación del programa porque incluye
el tema de los incendios también parecen
ser cada vez más virulentos y la causa
está dada precisamente por el tema del
calentamiento global el cambio climático
bueno y esa no es la única porque bueno
pues lo leí una noticia esta semana y
fue el primero de agosto no el 10 de
agosto o sea que en realidad dentro de
unos días
está comprobado que hemos agotado todos
los recursos naturales renovables del
y ya todos los recursos renovables es
decir que todo lo que estamos
produciendo para alimentar al mundo a
partir del 10 de agosto en adelante
estamos tomando lo prestado de el año
que viene esto qué quiere decir la agua
el agua las plantaciones los animales o
sea la cantidad de consumo que el hombre
está
a la que está expuesto no ha limitado la
capacidad que tiene la tierra para
regenerarse para poder seguir
produciendo como corresponde
efectivamente y eso a pesar de todas las
advertencias científicas que existen
alrededor de los agotamiento de los
recursos naturales etcétera etcétera
pero parece ser que nos cuestan más de
lo que creíamos tomar conciencia del
tema si igual en realidad fue el primero
de agosto y dice que se acabaron los
recursos naturales renovables que el
planeta tenía para el 2018 la fecha más
adelantada en 46 años según un cálculo
de global footprint network una ong que
hace este tipo de estudios ahora en el
tema específico de los incendios que
decía rufo aquí en canadá puntualmente
hay incendios en este momento en este
preciso instante en columbia británica y
en la provincia de ontario efectivamente
con pérdidas de territorio de terreno en
todo caso que se dedica habitualmente a
los cultivos y a la cría de ganado y que
ha quedado arruinado por las llamas por
el fuego con casas que han sido
destruidas con autos que han resultado
quemados con población que ha tenido
será evacuada ante el peligro que
implica la cercanía del fuego tanto en
columbia británica como en ontario es
algo que se vive todos los años en
durante el verano como decíamos pero que
año tras año parece ser que va
tornándose cada vez más violento este
fenómeno de incendios forestales e
incendios estivales como me gusta decir
amén bueno y justamente en este sentido
lo que me llamó la atención esta semana
eran eran 22 noticias el orden en que
estaban colocadas dentro la parrilla de
informaciones y la primera decía es
científicos del mundo declaran que el
reglamento del planeta ha afectado todas
las regiones y que se manifiesta a
través de estos fenómenos y la segunda
noticia era que el gobierno de canadá
decidió reducir el impuesto al carbono
ya visitó una medida implementada
justamente para combatir el mercado de
planeta y reducir para mantener la
competitividad con estados unidos es
decir realmente hay uno se plantea la
pregunta bueno hasta qué punto
somos efectivamente racionales porque si
vives tu casa y estás haciendo apaleada
y tu pareja empieza a quemar a casa
entonces dejarías de usa la parrilla por
lo menos la lógica indica eso no pero en
este caso creo que la realmente es es la
razón llegó a su agotó y dejando de lado
los incendios algo tan trágico como los
incendios ya de hecho el calor se está
viviendo una ola de calor inédita en el
mundo creo que para esta semana no sé si
no era exactamente incluso hoy se
esperaba en españala el pico de calor
más alto de su historia
eso puede ser increíble porque hay
estado en españa en agosto y eso es para
sufrir si a los amigos españoles y
realmente estando en madrid en agosto
uno llega a la conclusión sintiendo ese
calor que además no está al ciento en el
centro del país no hay mar etcétera
sintiendo ese calor uno puede imaginar
porque la idea de la ley de la
inquisición y el infierno fue creada en
ese contexto vos pensás que es por el
calor que sufría efectivamente es la
explicación posible bueno y que ese
calor que se está viviendo que está
llegando a su pico por estos días en
españa también se ha producido en grecia
también se ha producido en gran bretaña
también lo estamos viendo aquí acá ha
habido días de calor increíble para esta
época del año es decir dichosos nosotros
que nos quejamos siempre del invierno
dichosos creo que estamos de tener un
poco de calor pero realmente
el termómetro ha trepado durante días y
días y días en marcas que son poco
habituales aquí en canadá y que en todo
caso si llegan a producirse se producen
durante periodos de tiempo mucho más
corto se alía esta mañana el informe del
medio meteorológico indicaba que hay una
diferencia de 10 grados en comparación a
la temperatura normal para esta época
del año estamos 10 grados por encima ha
comparado con qué porque la temperatura
promedio para este
2 de agosto o sea que no es solamente un
poquito más de calor 10 grados es
muchísima la diferencia en el domingo
llegaremos a 29 o 30 y el festival de
música nos llega están recordando a la
gente que se hidrate y que colocan a
inclusive una vía estaciones de donde
lanzan vapor de agua los pasa nos dss
ese entonces se viene por menos ahí hay
medidas que tienen que tomarse en cuenta
por eso quienes somos previsores
mentiras de pura casualidad hemos
elegido este fin de semana para irnos
del campamento entonces vamos a recibir
yo voy a recibir el calor que va a ser
el domingo que aparentemente va a ser
mucho haciendo campamento a unos 200
kilómetros de aquí de montreal en una
buena idea para no morirse de calor en
ofrecerá un banquete abierto los
mosquitos
no tienes que me fui de campamento
precisamente no eran mosquitos sino que
era la famosa música negra mosca negra
hacia heces carnívoras ya sería el hijo
se mueve dado de ghana no escapa muerde
por suerte en él
estaba estaban como localizadas en un
pequeño sector entonces si uno no pasaba
por ahí no tienen ningún problema pero
cuando pasaba por el lugar que era
precisamente en una en una salida
secundaria del campamento que nos
quedaba muy cerca del predio donde
estábamos nosotros así que pasábamos
frecuentemente por ahí te seguían y te
seguían y te seguían y cuando se
decidían a atacar te escuchamos decir no
es que te pican te arrancan los pedazos
son carne por pirañas con alas nos tenés
algún otro tema que te haya llamado la
atención más allá de esto que citaba del
si se cortó frescos durante cinco
minutos yo pero no nosotros no podía
acceder desde ningún dispositivo ahora
sí ahora funciones recientes y error
error disculpas error error error así
que por la pérdida de la bolsa en días
pasados al tener que sumar problemas
este técnico sí sí sí sí es un desastre
así que bueno no no nada más que eso
sólo que bueno estamos viviendo a
crédito la explicación que de este lugar
y de este sitio internet es como sí
uno hubiera cobrado el sueldo hasta el
mes de agosto y ahora hasta el mes de
diciembre hay que vivir con los ahorros
hay que vivir con esto así que bueno en
esas estamos
el crédito se regenera los recursos
naturales no exacto y sabiendo y
sabiendo a ciencia cierta de que marte
no es habitable el ciclo agua no
encontraron agua pero inmediatamente
después dijeron que con todos los los
chiquillos quisieran a partir de
justamente haber encontrado agua en la
vida no es viable en el planeta rojo por
menos de como algunos vemos aquí exacto
es allá no sé si por ahí como en la
película schwarzenegger donde se había
hecho una base ciclar vientos dentro de
esa base
probablemente sí pero de las tres
plantas falsas en las películas falsas y
señal pero igual digamos no no no se
podría no podemos decir bueno nos
deshacemos de este que nos está tratando
mal con el clima y nos vamos al otro
pero eventualmente ss este cifra hopkins
decía el que finalmente sea la única
salida para ser humano para su
continuidad es es justamente dejar el
planeta porque podría haber sí sí se
aprende algo no porque finalmente es me
acuerdo hace años hace años no sé si se
acuerdan ustedes amigos oyentes que no
están bien en este momento quizá
recuerdan esa campaña que había en los
países africanos para contener el sahara
que había campañas de plan de plantado
de árboles y el sahara crecía con no sé
cuántos centímetros o metros por año y
eso desapareció del mapa ya nadie habla
mucho de eso porque me imaginaba saque
el desierto son se extendió casi todo el
planeta y si exageramos un poco la
situación y según si no me equivoco bien
paleontólogos y explicaban quienes fue
antigua
es el sahara era una región tropical era
una región que de árboles llena de vida
bueno recuerdo un estudio científico que
viese allá a varios meses atrás no no no
no
no recuerdo los detalles pero había
científicos que decían y no en broma
sino con carácter científico de que en
un futuro por supuesto no muy cercano
pero futuro al fin el canadá que
conocemos hoy en día no va a existir más
porque si el cambio climático continúa y
se sigue acelerando como se va
acelerando año tras año ya nada va a
terminar siendo una zona tropical del
planeta entonces nos hacemos cubanos
podríamos vamos a seguir las elevaciones
el problema también es que con el
derretimiento de los polos o parte de
ellos el nivel del agua va a subir
entonces las partes costeras tampoco van
a existir está bien o sea esa es una
protección también a largo plazo pero
implica que montreal va a estar bajo el
agua por ejemplo nuestros amigos oyentes
no estén buscando
emparentado con esto tengo una noticia
que publique hoy que tiene tiene
relación con el cambio climático también
y es el de una mujer de 95 años de edad
de la provincia de columbia británica en
el oeste canadiense que mientras se
encontraba en su vivienda disfrutando de
los programas de televisión que ella
acostumbra a ver escuchó un ruido
extraño en la cocina un ruido extraño y
al decidir seguir a ver qué es lo que
sucedía se encontró que es el ruido y
ese ruido lo producía un oso que se
había introducido en la cocina de su
casa no era el marido no no era el
marido el marido sin camisa es ahora ana
esther y que es como dije una mujer de
95 años de edad lejos de preocuparse de
asustarse de gritar de intentar huir le
hizo frente a los y dijo por favor toma
asiento un traguito
no lo invito precisamente con un trago
pero lo invito muy cortésmente
retirarse ella dice que le dijo
simplemente que se fuera
en lugar de asustarse de correr de huir
dijo
vete de aquí no hay no tienes nada que
hacer aquí en mi casa y el oso
respondidos o aparentemente en un primer
momento entendió que esta mujer no
estaba interesada en recibir su visita
en ese momento y salió de la casa
pero la señora desconfiada o en todo
caso para querer asegurarse de que no se
fuera a quedar escondido por ahí óseo se
fuera hacia algún otro ambiente de su
vivienda
se quedó mirando unos minutos y este oso
se entretuvo en el parque de su casa
luego el perro
césar cáceres buscando algo que le
llamara la atención algo para jugar
atrás dejó tal vez buscando comida o una
cosa luego desapareció se perdió
aparentemente las estrellas en la osa
mayor se perdió en el bosque inflación
era world vio a bird un programa de
televisión y más tarde nuevamente los
ruidos extraños en la cocina a las
volcaba va a la cocina a ver que estaba
pasando y se encuentra otra vez al
bendito oso en la cocina de saia gusto
entonces pero esta vez había ya ha
encontrado un frasco un recipiente en el
cual la mujer tenía azúcar
le había tirado el piso y se estaba
comiendo parte del contenido de este
recipiente cuando la señora dijo bueno
ya suficiente ya tiene que estar saciado
lo he hecho pero esta vez si se fue
aunque desapareció en el bosque y a la
baja dijo que ella no tuvo nunca ningún
momento ni miedo ni temor por su vida ni
pensó en que yo sola pudiese atacar ni
mucho menos y porque ella explicó que
noriega está familiarizada con la
presencia de osos cercana a su casa a su
casa no está en un lugar aislado está en
una zona donde hay otras viviendas
algunas de ellas contiguas a la suya
pero que está acostumbrada a la
presencia de osos porque estos se
acercan cada vez más como yo han dicho
ya inclusive varios estudios científicos
se acercan cada vez más a los lugares
habitados por las personas en busca de
comida
tenemos más hecho ganar en busca de
comida fácil exactamente y por qué
porque precisamente a raíz del cambio
climático al que nos referíamos hace
sólo unos instantes los osos carecen del
alimento habitual en sus zonas de
ecosistemas y tienen que acercarse cada
vez más a las poblaciones
a ver si dentro de los botes de basura
que tiene la gente habitualmente fuera
de sus casas encuentran algo que puedan
comer pues no hay un testigo de estos
encuentros bueno no lo sé pero la mujer
no lo contó a los medios de comunicación
y realmente a mí me llama la atención
primero que una mujer de 95 años tenga
la valentía y la energía suficiente como
para sacar un oso de su casa sin
preocuparse demasiado por lo que pueda
ocurrir pero digamos hay autoridades
provinciales creo que ese sí tengo aquí
la oficina de conservación de columbia
británica recordó que la presencia de
osos y la posibidad de que éstos puedan
introducirse en las viviendas implica
desde luego un peligro y una amenaza
significativos
porque hay un relato una leyenda inuit
brevemente para que nuestros amigos
sepan de qué se trata había pues son
como son pueblos los viajan bastante en
uno de esos viajes que hacían
polo norte había la abuela y la abuela
que avanzaba más despacio y entornos
deciden que van a poner al final de la
fila de la caminata con la idea
finalmente que pues de exhalar como un
oso
huele entonces va a la familia caminando
y efectivamente viene un oso y de unos
un oso polar y esos no son no son tan
amigos tan amigables entonces ibai y
atacan a la viejita la abuelita entonces
lo que hace a white es que agarra iii y
iv y empuja un guante suyo un guante un
crema
no me acuerdo nombre en nn pero empuja
al guante en la boca del oso y el oso
muere sofocado entonces ya aprendí civil
he casado un oso entonces toda la
familia séptica va a ver y efectivamente
a la bonita caso acabó con un oso
entonces tienen comida etcétera entonces
creo que la moraleja pues de esto es que
no puede ser pensar de esa forma de que
los viejitos los viejitos los no sirven
para nada las personas mayores ni para
nada no las dejes para los osos porque
ellos pueden darte de comer entonces esa
es una historia justamente hablando de
osos bueno osos no hay en todas partes
pero nuestro público que nos y en todas
partes del mundo y sobre todo en el
mundo de habla hispana en españa y en
américa latina donde hay una gran
variedad de animales de todo tipo de
veces hay encuentros con animales que
uno no sospecha los invitamos a quienes
nos siguen a través de internet de las
redes sociales a través de facebook live
a través de youtube a que nos cuenten si
han tenido experiencias de este tipo sin
nosotros o yo viví han salido del estero
nosotros tuvimos una experiencia si
media visa
con respecto a un animal de trabajar a
las tres de la mañana de santiago del
estero hace muchísimo calor muchísimo
calor y estábamos todos durmiendo en la
pieza de mis padres que era la única que
tenía aire acondicionado y un tipo tres
y media cuatro a la mañana se siente un
ruido en la cocina y nosotros vivimos un
departamento que era en realidad la
planta baja era de otra persona nosotros
habíamos primero segundo piso y una
terraza
y había una especie de
traiga luz pero grande que daba hacia la
cocina una especie de participo que da
base a la cocina con un gran regalo y
escuchamos ruidos en la cocina y es
imposible entrada si no entras por la
puerta o si no entras por ahí es
imposible escuchar ruidos ahí y mi padre
se aproximó y se encontró con un
avestruz una vez tres un simio una anda
viendo agua y llamó a la policía
no lo creían o sea que hace como un mes
si efectivamente lo hay y el animalito
no era agresivo o se lo vio mi padre y
no animalito del poco más alto que me
pasa si una gallina de este tamaño
y mi padre él dijo bueno lo voy a sacar
a la flor no no no y lo sacó bajo un
piso con el animal a cuestas agua o que
-según después nos enteramos era no era
adulto era joven y resultó que bueno
después vino la policía y tal y la
historia es a fin de cuentas se había
escapado no le habían cortado bien las
alas había volado por encima de las
rejas se han escapado el zoológico que
quedaba cerca de nuestra casa
y cayó ahí y por ello era digamos no
amistoso pero tampoco descreído del
contacto de la gente porque bueno esa es
la gente que la alimentaba y ya fuera
entonces los invitamos a quienes nos
siguen a través de los distintos canales
de difusión que tenemos aquí en radio
canadá internacional a que nos comenten
si han tenido experiencias con animales
de algún tipo ya sea con osos con nubes
con la destruye o con que con cualquier
otro tipo de animal
productor músico brasileño que vive en
winnipeg y los invito a escuchar canadá
en las américas café de la radio canadá
internacional en la web
[Música]
bueno y les recuerdo que para que nos
sigan a través de la emisión en internet
de nuestro programa podrán escuchar
temas musicales del artista jon bernard
que es originario de la provincia de
alberta y que es militante por los
derechos indígenas en este país antes de
pasar a otras cuestiones los invito a
leer algunos de los mensajes que nos han
hecho llegar nuestros oyentes en los
últimos días quien quiere comenzar aquí
tenemos uno que nos envía mixtos
moore y torres quien ha escuchado el
reportaje santa clotilde en perú una
relación profunda con canadá y él dice
en su mensaje desde el perú me imagino
un ejemplo a seguir
logros que se dan con el desinteresado
apoyo y sacrificio de buenas personas
gracias dice víctor morí torres desde
buenos aires susana sana ante una
pregunta en torno a un reportaje que
hizo creo que eso le honor a avance
importante para mejorar la visión de
pacientes con glaucoma en el tema
y es que dice escribo desde argentina
buenos aires y pregunta es seguro y está
puesto en opción de tratamientos el tema
de las gotas de insulina para la retina
y por ende para los que padecemos
glaucoma me interesaría tener mayor
información y de ser algo probado para
consumo donde conseguirlo
obviamente previa consulta como logo
muchas gracias dice susana shanahan y
obviamente como es la pregunta médica
pues corresponderá a la sana sana ganas
ya en buenos aires y acudir a su médico
y proxy a su oftalmólogo tiene mucha más
autoridad que nosotros para responderle
la consigue igual el glaucoma
es una de las primeras
de los primeros síntomas que aparecen
luego de una diabetes consumada y así
que probablemente con el diabetólogo
también tenga algún tipo de solución y
una voz o algún mensaje si aquí tengo
mensaje de verónica navarro va velázquez
y dice muchas gracias por la linda
música que puedo escuchar toda la noche
bajito volumen dice es darme aliento y
continuidad en el teatro municipal las
condes como en el coro de tabletas y en
las condes es chile
profesional en el próximo mes de agosto
gracias por divulgar su línea músicas y
saludos desde chile entonces decía
verónica navarro velázquez yo por mi
parte quiero agradecer a quienes hacen
llegar mensajes relacionados a los
planes de inmigrar el plan inmigración
en canadá como así también a las
distintas consultas laborales es el caso
del sida rosa ovalles silva lo de indira
a peng las rudy maisel molano darling
yajaira casco castillo y serafín álvarez
todos ellos nos consultan sobre
distintas cuestiones laborales en canadá
y sobre el plan de inmigración y como
hemos dicho en varias ocasiones cada uno
de los organismos pertinentes tiene la
información en su sitio en internet otro
mensaje después de haber estado en la
tierra de los tangos y el chamamé con su
sanación agentes vamos a otro lugar que
no sé dónde es
porque no hay pautas sobre la ubicación
geográfica de nuestro amigo dimas
hernández quien dice hola leí un
artículo publicado en el 2015 donde se
trata sobre trabajar en la industria
pesquera de canadá y tengo una duda dice
dimas hernández dice yo como extranjero
italiano podría trabajar allí después
dimas hernández
la respuesta la encontrará en el sitio
en internet de inmigración que nada que
está disponible ahí en cualquier
computadora con jr muchísima muchísima
información para este tipo de cosas aquí
tengo otro mensaje en este caso de juan
pablo donoso que escribe desde quitó
desde ecuador y información de nuevo
migrante dice primero que todo reciban
un cordial saludo felicitó su servicio
informativo hacia la continuidad la que
hace a la comunidad la tiene en canadá
mi nombre es juan pabló vivo en ecuador
y estamos próximos a emigrar a canadá el
agua 2a y sus hijos específicamente a
winnipeg manitoba me gustaría saber si
me pueden brindar alguna información
acerca de alguna oficina donde pueda
encontrar ayuda a recién llegados a
ubicarse en esa ciudad lamentablemente
no conocemos a nadie de antemano un
abrazo grande agradezco su ayuda y la
solicitud cordialmente juan pablo donoso
bueno yo particularmente le digo juan
pablo que cuando uno entra a canadá con
una visa en este caso
digamos ya otorgada por el gobierno
canadiense visas de residencia
permanente residencia permanente en la
misma oficina cuando uno le hacen los
trámites al entrar le dan una carpeta
con toda la información del señor con la
información de los cursos de lenguas y
tiene que mejorar su lengua con los
cursos para preparar el currículum vitae
para poder trabajar con los cursos para
mostrar cómo funciona el sistema escolar
por ejemplo para los niños y después en
esos mismos cursos uno conoce más gente
que ya conoce otra gente y puede tener
contacto con organismos que se dedican
específicamente a ese tipo de ayudas y
hay muchos en montreal hay muchísimos
supongo que en winnipeg debe haber una
cantidad en todas las provincias con
exigencias de hecho ahora yo no sé si
será en todas las provincias el mismo
criterio pero por ejemplo aquí en quebec
cuando uno llega incluso como residente
permanente tiene un plazo de cinco años
en el cual puede solicitar todo tipo de
ayuda a
a un recién llegados durante los
primeros cinco años se considera la
persona como recién llegado y es
beneficiar entonces de una infinidad de
programas de orientación apoyo e
inserción laboral
mejora en el uso de la lengua como decía
leonardo etcétera etcétera etcétera si
está de winnipeg y efectivamente hay
centros de ayuda para los llegados y una
de las cosas más más prácticas que
también he visto que la gente hace
cuando llega acá es entre contacto con
iglesias en español y cualquier edad es
español es básicamente una fuente de
información hace distintas entidades
organismos etcétera entonces hay gente
que habla español a ingeniero
necesariamente si son digamos
profesantes de la católica no tiene nada
que ver las iglesias cumplen esa función
también para ayudar a los recientes
grados perfectos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno muy bien les recordamos que están
ustedes en canadá en las américas café
el espacio que todas las semanas le
brindamos desde el servicio en español
de radio canadá internacional canal a
las américas café o como les llamamos a
veces por su sobrenombre el castor
cibernético efectivamente y además de
esta emisión todas las semanas
producimos una gran cantidad de
materiales de diverso tipo entrevistas
reportajes etcétera que ustedes pueden
encontrar en nuestro sitio en internet
www r6 net punto sea barra e s de
español allí podrán encontrar diversos
materiales
ahora vamos a sugerirle solamente
algunos de ellos prosiguen o de los
temas que les recomiendo visitar para
entender un poco más que dará a conocer
un poco la relación que existe entre
canadienses indígenas y no indígenas es
justamente un reportaje sobre la lo que
se llama movilidad étnica y me llamó la
atención el nombre de movilidad étnica
porque esto se refiere justamente cuando
una persona decide identificarse como
y es justamente es lo que explica el
aumento de la población indígena
en la provincia de alberta que están las
praderas canadienses y es un aumento que
según los estudiosos no se debe a un
boom demográfico no se debe a una a una
a un aumento de nacimientos sino más
bien se debe a la movilidad étnica es
decir que hay más gente que se
identifica como indígenas y chris
anderson que es un profesor y decano de
la facultad de estudios indígenas en la
universidad de berta él explicaba que
esto se debe en parte por ejemplo a una
especie de reconocimiento de mucha gente
de sus propias raíces a partir y esto es
interesante aparte de una validación de
su historia
esto como por ejemplo como consecuencia
por ejemplo de la decisión del gobierno
federal de pedir disculpas a los
indígenas por estos internados que por
más de 100 años trataron de literalmente
eliminar la lecto de identidad o
herencia indígena en los niños indígenas
y acerados entre comillas canadienses
de cultura y eurocéntrica perdón rojo sí
entiendo bien es gente que antes no se
consideraba a sí misma o no se veía o no
se reconocía un solo caso como indígena
pero que ahora sí lo así lo hace
justamente porque se ha validado es otro
otro ejemplo es por ejemplo la disculpa
también del gobierno por lo que se llama
desde scoop the sixties scoop que quiere
decir básicamente que los años 60 un
gran número de niños fueron sacados de
familias y fueron puestos en adopción en
familias no indígenas entonces el
resultado también es esa erosión y
desaparición de la herencia indígena
entonces con esas con esos dos actos del
gobierno federal que valida la la
herencia indígena entonces esto ha
motivado a mucha gente y dice niños
gente que después de dos o tres
generaciones recién sale uno de ellos
para decir bueno efectivamente si soy
indígena aunque toda medalla tiene dos
lados y está siempre y más el otro lado
de medalla es que también hay gente que
se identifica como indígena
para conseguir beneficios fiscales lo
cual por ejemplo en el este de canadá
hay un grupo que hubo una investigación
de un grupo que se llaman indígenas pero
que no lo son y todo lo que hacen es
inclusive imprimen sus propias tarjetas
de indígenas para presentarse en los
comercios y no a pagar impuestos y
entonces hay de todo eso pero lo
concreto en alberta es que el número de
indígenas ha aumentado el 15% más que el
resto de población entre 2006 y 2016 que
son los dos años en que se llevó a cabo
el censo nacional y canadá cada 10 años
y esto no necesariamente significa un
incremento de la población general en
términos absolutos dentro de la
provincia sino como decíamos el hecho de
que hay gente que ha pasado a
reconocerse como integrante de esas
comunidades sin efectivamente indígenas
metis e inuit perfecto yo largo su tema
de la semana el tema que vos de sugerir
a nuestros oyentes el tema de la semana
tiene que ver con una nueva posibilidad
que saldrá pronto pronto
esto es pronto al cuadrado porque
facebook dueño también de instagram ha
puesto a disposición o va a poner a
disposición
una herramienta muy particular y es la
herramienta para que la gente pueda
controlar cuánto tiempo pasa dentro de
las redes sociales es decir una especie
de alarma
para evidenciar veamos el momento
preciso en que uno tiene uno se da
cuenta que pasa mucho tiempo entonces
puede setear esa alarma dentro de la
aplicación o dentro del web en teléfonos
tabletas y computadoras entonces la red
social instagram o facebook avisará a
esta persona y ya lleva una hora y media
haciendo esto por favor una hora y media
una hora y media de gente que yo conozco
bueno es una manera bueno a mí lo que me
sorprendió fue justamente fue el cto del
tiempo porque la alarma está se te da
para 15 minutos 12 38 horas o sea hay
gente que pasa 8 horas
haciendo haciendo mirando o participando
o vas a saber que en en facebook o
instagram esto ya había salido en
realidad algunos dicen que hay cosas más
de fondo que tenés que ver en facebook e
instagram antes que esto por ejemplo las
regulaciones para los niños es cierto
pero bueno eso se supone que vendrá en
un tiempo
y algunos especialistas se indican que
esto tiene que ver con ya algunos datos
que dieron tanto android como el papel
que iban a poner ese mismo tipo de
contadores en sus no en aplicaciones
sino realmente en el teléfono en sí para
que uno pueda ver cuánto tiempo gastan
mirando el aparato y pasando dentro de
interactuando con el aparato ahora yo te
soy sincero cuando vi el tema la
pregunta que me surgió la duda que me
surgió en todo caso es pues el trasfondo
de todo esto porque a mí me llamó mucho
la atención que las empresas que están
interesadas que vos las consumas como
por ejemplo facebook ponga un límite
para que vos utilice sus servicios
la pregunta fue la mía fue un poquito
más allá es se supone que uno tiene que
tener atrapado para poder vender t
en realidad nosotros ya no compramos
sobre sobre las redes sociales somos el
producto o sea nosotros estamos ahí para
que nos vendan entonces dónde está el
truco en realidad no lo sé
yo intuyo que tiene que ver con esta
desesperada búsqueda de de atrapar a la
gente después de la caída en la después
de este cambio es analítica después de
todo lo que pasó de los espías y tal
entonces yo creo que es una especie de
paso en adelante para poder volver a
captar la gente que se fue o captar más
gente y después bueno buscarán otros
otros caminos para poder seguir
vendiendo porque en realidad viven
gracias a la publicidad así que yo a mí
también me resultó medio raro el hecho
de ok te estoy diciendo estás pasando
mucho tiempo igualmente lo que quiero es
que pasen más tiempo para vender porque
más allá de que uno esté a favor o en
contra sea más adicto o menos adicto a
las redes sociales es verdad que en
algunos casos hay personas que se han
dejado prácticamente entre comillas de
llevar la vida por las redes sociales la
gente no voy a dar nombres pero conozco
gente que pasa horas y horas y en que
incluso es difícil entablar un diálogo
con esas personas porque a veces uno les
dice algo les habla y esta persona está
versa en el uso de su red social
comunicándose con alguien en otra parte
o respondiendo una foto o haciendo un
comentario o lo que fuera que no
reacciona a su entorno no evidentemente
es un problema y hay muchísimos trabajos
de investigación que hablan de esta
necesidad de estar allá adentro y que
también implica alejarse de la de afuera
o sea hay hay problemas mentales serios
aparte de los problemas físicos que
puede otorgarle a uno estar tanto tiempo
mirando una pantalla con esos ratos que
afectan el ciclo circadiano y todo lo
que está sabemos el tema de la necesidad
de estar adentro para ni siquiera
mostrarse uno porque lo que muestra uno
adentro no es la realidad está bien uno
hace una performance para estar y
adentro una actuación una actuación que
te deja aclarar que uno no probablemente
nos acepte como es y trata de hacerlo
hay un montón de campañas para tratar de
que la gente
deje de estar tanto tiempo es más en el
momento en el texto que escribí habla
también de que zuckerberg dijo que la
intención era que la gente pudiera
hablar más sobre los efectos de las
redes sociales
obviamente hablando de padres e hijos a
partir de esta barrera no los juegos que
se escapó el pájaro de la jaula
así que pero encuentro que hay una
previa en principio es contradictorio y
creo que tiene que ver mucho con la
presión social también para digamos
limitar el uso de interés pero ya no se
es
nadie sabe cuál será la siguiente etapa
porque la industria por claro sigue
inventando nuevos teléfonos se sigue
inventando nuevas nuevas aplicaciones se
habla ahora del internet de las de los
objetos se habla de la inteligencia
artificial entonces es todo un mundo
nuevo en que toda la psicología humana
cómo va a adaptarse a ese a esta nueva
eso es este mundo no bueno yo por mi
parte y muy sintéticamente porque ya
casi no nos queda tiempo los invito a
que escuchen una entrevista que le hice
a isa laura lópez y ella es una cineasta
mexicana que estuvo pocos días atrás
aquí en canadá presentando uno de sus
filmes en el marco del festival de
frontera que se llevó a cabo en la
ciudad de montreal su película es se
vuelven que también se la conoce por la
traducción al español de subtítulo en
inglés y esa traducción es los tigres no
tienen miedo es una película hiper
realista como la define ella en el cual
y saber con quien mantuve un diálogo muy
interesante se refiere a la realidad
mexicana de hoy en día inmersa en una
ola de violencia que ella misma dijo
excede los marcos de la realidad ella
dijo esto mi película no es fantasía la
fantasía es la propia realidad mexicana
que ha sobrepasado todos los límites y
que yo no soy capaz de llevar a la
pantalla decía issa lópez refiriéndose a
esa violencia que hoy en día que
envuelve a gran parte de la población
mexicana y que tiene entre sus
principales víctimas a los jóvenes ya
los niños que son el personaje central
de su fin y criticó muy duramente a esa
especie de visión romántica que a través
de los medios de comunicación se hace de
los capos de los cárteles de las drogas
porque dice que ellos son los culpables
junto con la clase política mexicana del
baño de sangre en el que se encuentra el
país y que son ellos los verdaderos
monstruos y no los que están en las
películas de terror o de tipo fantástico
como las que se proyectan
en este festival entonces los invito a
que escuchen esta entrevista crisis
y sal laura lópez y a los que puedan
también que vean a sus películas vuelven
que es bastante interesante por lo menos
eso es lo que yo pude ver a partir de la
promo que di la l en internet les
agradecemos a todos ustedes aquí su
presencia no nos queda más tiempo los
saludamos hasta la semana que viene nos
despedimos de todos los que nos siguen a
través de facebook live y los dejamos
entonces a quien nos siguen a través del
sitio en internet con más música de
gobernar en este caso
otro tema musical que es aprendiendo el
camino chau hasta la programa la próxima
gracias por estar con nosotros
[Música]